تعرضت موسكو العاصمه موسكو منذ ساعات
الصباح الاولى لهجوم جديد بمسيرات قالت
السلطات الروسيه انها اوكرانيه واشارت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الى انها قامت
باسقاط مسيرتين باستخدام وسائل الحرب
الالكترونيه وهاتين المسيرتين عمليه
اسقاطهم الحقت اضرار ماديه بمبنيين غير
ماهولين ونحن حاليا يعني نتواجد على مقربه
من احد هذه هذين المبنيين وكما تبدو
الصوره خلفي هذا هذا الحادث اسفر عن اضرار
او الحق اضرار ماديه
بالطابقين العلويين من هذا المبنى وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه وصفت هذا العمل بالارهابي
اما الناطق باسم الخارجيه ماريا زخاربه
فوصفته بالارهاب الدولي بالاشاره لان كل
الاهداف التي تقوم كيف بضربها يتم تنسيقها
بشكل مباشر مع مع الولايات المتحده ومع
المستشارين البريطانيين من جانبه نائب
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي دمت اشار الى ان
اوكرانيا تعمل على تفعيل هجماتها
بالمسيرات على خلفيه فشلها في الهجوم
المضاد مشيرا الى انها بهذه الطريقه تحاول
تحقيق نجاحات على الساحه الاعلاميه